what does it take to build a custom
object recognition global app starting
from raw data we'll find out on this
episode of cloud AI adventures today
we're joined by Sarah Robinson a
developer advocate on my team it also
focuses on machinima she created an app
that recognizes pictures of Taylor Swift
and she joins me today in the studio to
discuss how she accomplished it welcome
Sarah thanks for joining me thanks for
having me super excited to be on AI
adventures so you wrote a sensational
medium article I've got open here about
your Swift detector which kind of
showcases end-to-end machine learning
from gathering and pre-processing the
data to training and serving from cloud
machine learning engine and there's even
firebase and an iPhone app in the mix
lots of different tools yeah definitely
it's it's super amazing what inspired
this project so I've seen a couple of
other blog posts on the tensor field
object detection API and I've been
wanting to try it out these blog posts
did things like detecting pets whether
there was a cat or a dog in an image I
saw another one about detecting raccoons
oh wow
so then I thought I wants to try it on
my own with some of some training data
that I found and the easiest thing I
thought of was to just look at my Google
photos and find all the pictures of
myself right to train a model to
recognize me had lots of selfies so I
had enough training data yeah and that
search function on Google photos super
oh it's pretty great yeah so I trained
that model locally it works pretty well
but I wanted to build an end-to-end demo
and I know a little bit of Swift so I
thought it'd be cool if I built a iOS
client to make a prediction request
against my model which made me think why
don't I build a model to detect Taylor
Swift because why not Swift with Swift
perfect so it looks like here you're
using the tensor flow object detection
API to find Taylor Swift in these
pictures can you talk a little bit about
what that is and how you use it moves it
like to use it yeah sure so the object
detection API is some utilities that
make it easier to recognize objects in
an image so rather than just classifying
an image as this image has a cat in it
it'll return bounding boxes of where
that
object is in the image and to do that
it's using a technique called transfer
learning okay which utilizes a model
that's already been trained on a similar
classification task using millions and
millions of images and then what what I
do as a developer using object detection
API is I take the check points of the
second-to-last layer of that model
that's been trained on millions of
images and then I update it with my own
data so that I don't need to start from
scratch so I didn't have time to label
millions of images of Taylor Swift
though I'm sure you wouldn't have minded
right I wouldn't have minded going
through all those pictures yeah so I
just needed to use a smaller set of
training data to update the final layer
of that model fantastic that you can
kind of stand on the shoulders of giants
all the work and all the training that's
already been done on these models that's
one of the great things about transfer
learning yeah was the training kind of
quicker as a result because you didn't
have to go through as many images much
faster so instead of taking maybe days
it took just a couple hours fantastic
awesome
and then so actually doing the work then
right I guess you would have had to
somehow get the images and do any
pre-processing required to have the
tensorflow object detection API kind of
consume those images whatever formatting
you needed to do and then actually run
the training mm-hmm so the object
detection API requires your images being
what's called a TF record format TF
record okay and to get them in the flat
format I converted my images to what's
called the Pascal doc format which is
just one format you can choose from it
stands for visual object classification
okay
and what that is is that's an XML file
so I take all my images and I generate
this XML file which gives me details on
the bounding box where the object is so
that's what's in the XML is just kind of
coordinates here of the so it has the XY
coordinates of where my object is in the
image and then it just has the label
associated with that bounding box in
this case I just have one label Taylor
Swift only need one only need one
awesome
so then let's see we we have our data
it's labeled and I guess now only one
thing to do hit the training yeah so
training is next so with all the
kind of steps you just outline and how
they all connect together mm-hmm so I
drew the bounding boxes around my images
got them into the Pascal format right
and then once they're in that format I
wrote a script to convert them to a TF
record which I can then use to feed into
my model gotcha
okay so all of these kind of steps now
they're all connected we've gone from
the raw image to a well not just a label
image but specifically TF records have
been formatted correctly so now we're
ready for our training that's right and
so in this case we're gonna do our
training on and knowledge and it looks
like this on your of your blog post here
yep how is that process and of what what
did you have to do to make that work so
it was similar to the process I used for
running the training locally the main
difference being I needed to put all of
my data in Google Cloud storage right
and tell ml engine where to find it so
the first thing I needed to get in
Google Hut storage was the the model
check points from the pre-training model
I was using I used a model called mobile
nuts
she's optimized for mobile obviously so
I put those checkpoints in my cloud
storage bucket I also needed my training
and test TF record files which I talked
about before how I generated those and
then I have a config file which tells
the object detection API where my
training and test data is located and it
supports ml engine and Google Cloud
Storage great great and so that whole
thing kind of comes together and I guess
just takes care of all training for you
then awesome and how long did that
training kind of take everyone wants to
know you know if the training takes a
long time or a little time how long you
had to wait for that I think you took
about 30 minutes 30 minutes okay yeah
yeah given what you're getting out of it
exactly but nice
so once trainings done you what do you
have kind of as your result what do you
have in your hands so you have a model
checkpoint which is just a binary file
similar to the pre train model
checkpoint that I used to start training
this is now going to be the final model
checkpoint which has been updated with
all of my training data okay so that's
that's very nice and then you I guess
but now kind of flip it over the wall to
the serving side so for to serve it I
can use on a g-cloud command with ml
engine to deploy my model I just need to
point it at where those checkpoint files
of my final train model okay um and then
in just a couple of minutes I have my
model available for serving and I can
use that to generate predictions against
the model fantastic and so I guess this
kind of brings us to the next next phase
of this project we've gone from our data
we've pre-processed it we've done the
training mm-hm and we have there was
this kind of API that can serve up
predictions at scale so now we're ready
to call that endpoint and what did you
end up architecting here looks like you
have a couple of couple of pieces it's
using a couple of different firebase
SDKs so the client is a swift app it's
an iOS app that's written in Swift and
it's a pretty thin client so all the
client is doing is it's uploading an
image to firebase storage okay so that's
what that error is for exactly and then
we're using the firebase SDK for cloud
functions so a function is triggered
whenever an image is uploaded to a
specific storage bucket so the function
is written and nodejs and that function
does a bunch of different things it
downloads the image and then it resizes
it it base64 encode zit which will
prepare it for the ml engine online
prediction requests okay so I make that
prediction request if the confidence
that I get back is greater than 70%
that's just a threshold that I've chosen
I'm gonna draw a box around that image
okay so that's then the box trying is it
looks like it's happening here in your
node code yeah I'm doing that using
imagemagick which is available in Google
Cloud functions perfect very convenient
and so then once the box is drawn to you
how do you get that information back to
a client then so once the box is drawn
I write the image to firebase storage
and then I also write some metadata on
the image to cloud fire store which is a
database so i'm writing the the
confidence of the detection along with
the path of the image and firebase
storage so that's why you kind of have
these to write operations coming from
your cloud function exactly and the
reason I'm using firestore is in my
client I can create a listener on the ID
of that image path and so then I get
updates whatever new data has been added
to that collection in fire store so I
don't have to keep pulling yeah holding
that to see if the detection is finished
right when it's finished my client will
get an update and then I can then
download the new image of the box around
it right along with the confidence
detection score so that's really neat
that you've managed to use the kind of
architecture to signal in both
directions right you upload to cloud
storage and that triggers the cloud
function so you on upload something
happens and it happens right away and
then coming back once the response from
ml engine is received you're using fire
starter to basically give that real-time
update to hit your phone right away as
well so you kind of keep that loop tight
even though you've managed to do this
while all the while maintaining this
kind of thin client that's really nice
that the way you've kind of leveraged
the existing technology you didn't have
to write anything to make sure
everything happened nice and quick but
async yeah one thing that's great about
firebase is I get those real-time
updates whenever new data comes in that
path fantastic so I guess zooming out a
little bit you know you've built the
mobile app that builds a custom machine
learning model you collect your data
you've annotated it your training and
you're serving at scale to your mobile
client what did you find to be kind of
most interesting part of all of this I
would say definitely learning to tie
together all these different tools so
there's a lot of different things I use
to build the app ferment and from
tentacle
object section to cloud machine learning
engine which had a couple of different
components it had training serving and
online prediction and then the client
piece using some Swift SDKs and firebase
SDK for cloud functions
yeah I'm just along the way you're
hitting Python node Swift Java square
with Java Script is there even a little
bit of bash with the geo commands yeah
outstanding and so on the whole way did
you find to be most challenging and kind
of out of all of this the most
challenging part was getting all of the
data into Google Cloud storage because
there's a lot of different pieces that
needed to be there from the the
pre-trained model checkpoints the TF
records and then that config file which
tells object detection where to find
these different pieces right and these
are all coming kind of from different
places
getting it all arranged yeah I could see
how that could be challenging and this
was it was there some fun parts as well
hopefully along the way it was it was
pretty fun to build one thing that was
kind of funny was as I was I labeled all
the images myself so there was a day I
know it's a tough job so there was a day
where I had pictures of Taylor Swift on
my computer people walked by you're
probably wondering what I was doing
yeah he's perusing my photos all day
exactly generating those bounding boxes
and the most fun thing was definitely
the final result of seeing on the iOS
app the prediction with the bounding box
come back in real time definitely yeah
that's a long journey it was awesome and
as I understand you've actually open
sourced your code on github mm-hmm yeah
it's all available on my personal github
repo and there's instructions in the
readme if you want to build the same
model yourself awesome so it's that's so
great that our audience can go out and
build their own model and I want to
thank you so much you know really
appreciate you coming in today and
chatting the studio thanks for having me
it's great to be here that's been great
thanks for watching this episode of
cloud AI adventures today we saw how to
go from raw data to training to a mobile
client you can use sarah's github repo
to not only recreate this but extend it
with your own data a different model or
a different client emblem for more
details of we've included links to all
the resources we discussed in the
description so check it out
and if you've enjoyed this episode
please like it and subscribe to get more
episodes right when they come
[Music]
so the object detection API is more of a
series of so I'm going to read Annette
what does it take to build a custom
image recognition what does it take to
build a custom record a custom object
recognition mobile app